[Music]  hey I'm Haley  hello down the road Amelia they say  you're what like allergic to the world  right I guess you could say that they  looked everywhere for a doctor to help  you usually get better promise punished  hello Eli I'm dr. horn hello I hope you  don't think of this as a medical  facility to me it's a home and for now  it's your home but so everything we  hoped for is right here shall we begin  what do you think is making you sick  lots of things the air water dust Eli's  gonna get worse before he gets better  throw something in my room  bad dreams are a side effect it's  perfectly normal I don't need to freak  you out with this place gives me the  creeps  I think she's making me sicker no it's  not the medication why do I feel worse  because it's working  I think something bad is happening  [Music]  you're doing it better from us  [Music]  [Music]